Дашкін йому та початковому закладі для
дітей з поразкою та слухом
сторони система за 1 розвиваючі
колективної роботи я кас прямого на
розвиток мови та мовлення розвиток сухого
вас прямо не я формування ви йому ви ніку
проводити сурдопедагога на спеціальних
за нитках даю вітаю наше волосся буду ж
добра воля бідно соня вибрати
а соня молодих шкірних троянд роботи моя
коректний usb роман ванної та поневолюючи
згортання , ми розвиваємо його
характеру
корова помітили слово тидищ
дубль та лисиця
100 зуба мене б'є по корекції автор і
Михайло дипалом
роздаток малим блискавки інший дитя різьблених
лезинів працює до брудних видих
ці дія проводяться тут ми начебто
б і дня дикому сонце марина думали там
сонце he
вона лідер його куприк йдіть ви сьогодні
chardonnay
коло філат побути квадрат
перемогти вона нам і 100 / чотири роки
david яскравий
дерево знай доповіді
фонду
бо бо так лава і виголеного ті скарги
то
це
пілот
відома
рахунок і pin краще з прямий матеріал так
і гу-гу-гу на бойовому winter з особливими
возити економіст дітей друк, що летить
пір частини
я як рим коректний у вас перебування
форму я вич у тебе чудово в другій
радості
колективно видно плювану роботу з
дітьми з порушенням послуг нам вже but i
повне взагалі на легше ти їх уже тоді з
комплексі
ніби цілком нами в суді ніг видно за
класний
основою культури є взаємовигляд носа між
дітьми та дорослими чому не призначаючи на
важливим я формування заганяй легень
тінистої доброти та щедрості нині дружить
і в мене виявляти цю роботу мене ніби
у вічному формуванні любов цього то
чого чим світла
лежати у
і одні з кутку пастою роботи з дітьми з
порушенням слуху
я формування позитивних емоцій
допомогти так ти не знає їх забирайтеся
формула пельмені це заради сну пожити у
еда робопес вид стану
удачу youtube а потім на вигляд ніс та пизду
на коди шниву кольору означають за
класний фундамент мої будні числових
даних